hallo mein Name ist willkommen meine
Damen und Herren ich liebe
Straßenumfragen
weil ich mich da immer
nicht ganz so dumm fühlt und auf diesem
Grund wurden wir einige Straßen und
Fragen rausgesucht auf die wir heute mal
reagieren werden
die Gehirnzellen werden absolut
verschwinden wie viele Tage hat eine
Woche
[Musik]
nein
das muss Fake sein es muss einfach genau
das hoffe ich auch was ist H2O
oh es ist es tut so weh was sagst du
nicht
[Musik]
war Sauerstoff nicht Hartz IV
wie viele Bundesländer hat Europa
[Musik]
es ist auf so
unfassbar vielen Ebenen
[Musik]
ich
weiß gar nicht wo ich anfangen soll
beste Kondom Werbung
das weiß ich nicht lohnt sich was über
[Musik]
[Applaus]
oh mein Gott das kann
nicht gescriptet sein
das kann was hat sie ja eigentlich für
ein Teppich an wohin bei der ersten
Frage wie viele Bundesländer in Europa
Bundesländer Deutschland so wie viele
Länder hat Europa dann die Frage okay
das kann man fragen sie antwortet mit
Kontinenten Afrika Asien ergibt gar
keinen Sinn und dann sagt sie über 20
warte ist die Erde überhaupt so groß
Digger
für mich ist es gerade wie vor so einer
Matte Klausur wo die Lehrerin sagt er
hat irgendwer noch Fragen und du bist so
hohl dass du nicht mal weißt was du
nicht weißt sag meine genaue Zeit 21 ist
eine Zahl dann 21,5
[Musik]
wie viele Bundesländer hat Europa und
die Antwort ist eine Kommazahl also die
Fragen sind halt auch frech gestellt wie
soll so ein halbes fallenbundes Essen
gibt alles mein Kopf ist nicht gemacht
dafür ist es 8:30 Uhr morgens wie viele
Menschen leben in Deutschland
7,500 Millionen 7,5
das kann nicht Fake sein das kann nicht
Fake sein in die Kommentaren okay es
steht in den Kommentaren alles voll mit
Ey das muss geschnitten sein das muss
safe sein das muss keine Ahnung was aber
wie kommst du denn darauf
7,500 zu sagen fünf Mal beten aber ganz
schnell wie viel Leben dann hier in
Hannover
[Musik]
7,5 Millionen Einwohner hat also
Deutschland angeblich davon 3 Millionen
in Hannover was ist H2O
was sagst du
was Meilen
der erste Hashtag ist auch immer
Frankfurt was ist die Hauptstadt von
Europa oh Gott
Berlin ist glaube ich die mittigste
Hauptstadt von dem Land in Europa oder
Deutschland ist auch die Mitte von
Europa ich glaube kein Land hat so viele
angrenzende Länder in Europa wie
Deutschland deswegen sind ja bei uns
auch immer so viele sind super
Handelspartner von allen möglichen
anderen Ländern aber das war echt
interessant wenn wenn Europa so eine
Hauptstadt hätte irgendwas sagst du
[Musik]
wo liegt der Eiffelturm oder sowas
so ist auch in Europa
[Musik]
liegt nicht in Europa
Herr steht in welchem Land war der
Mauerfall
Bruder
ist ein Ohr drin
[Musik]
das kann nicht sein
das kann nicht sein der selbst wenn das
gescriptet werden sowas kannst du nicht
Skripten das ist das kann das geht nicht
viele Hauptstädte hat Frankfurt
[Musik]
in mich gehe und hinterfrage was mein
Beruf ist hier
wie viele Zahlen gibt es
leider nicht ganz richtig
[Musik]
was ist die Mehrzahl von Apfel Mehrzahl
von Apfel
[Musik]
es ist mir mittlerweile egal ob es
gescriptet ist oder nicht es ist das
unterhaltsamste an Straßen und fragen
was ich je gesehen habe Mehrzahl
richtig
[Musik]
der tut hier ist schwankt bei der Frage
was die Mehrzahl von Apfel ist zwischen
a und drei Apfel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie viel Kontinente hat Europa
[Musik]
viele Sekunden hat eine Minute 24
was ist die Hauptstadt von Deutschland
[Musik]
wenn man so ein paar geschichtliche
Dinge nicht weiß
obwohl das ja nicht mal Geschichte ist
sondern Allgemeinwissen also ein paar
Sachen nicht weiß so wäre es unser
Außenminister wer ist unser
Verteidigungsminister sonnenkrams okay
aber unsere Hauptstadt
wir machen noch eine allerletzte Frage
was ist die Hauptstadt von Frankfurt
macht